c'est l'habitude depuis la période covid
les terrasses éphémères se mettent en
place à Tours mais le lancement est
timide freiné par la pluie malgré le
mauvais temps certains bravent quand
même les quelques gouttes qui tombent
Sarah gros les a rencontrés
elles apparaissent timidement dans
quelques rues de la ville les terrasses
éphémères font leur tour sous un temps
peu accueillant chez les gens heureuxs
rue Marceau elles sont installées depuis
le début du mois mais faute de soleil
elles ont du mal à séduire les clients
en avril te découvre pas d'un
film on sent avec la météo mais
qui sont heureux de se mettre en
Terrasson ça nous apporte déjà une
meilleure visibilité pour nos clients et
un meilleur confort aussi donc dès qu'il
y a les rayons de soleil les gens aiment
bien les manger dehors un bol d'air qui
rapporte 30 couverts en plus pour le
restaurant c'est aussi le cas pas très
loin rue Maréchal Foch au gourmandises
maintenant nous avons les terrasses
c'est d'ailleurs on a une meilleure
visibilité les gens nous disent et les
gens ont envie de manger dehors quoi
profiter du soleil
c'est notre ambiance et nous ça nous
apporte beaucoup de plus de clients on a
le temps n'est pas avec nous donc faut
attendre vraiment la belle saison
même si le soleil pointe difficilement
le bout de son nez certains
établissements ne se laissent pas
abattre pour contrer la pluie le secret
c'est le parasol qu'il vente ou qu'il
pleuve certains clients ne s'empêchent
pas de se faire plaisir
pour reprendre un verre on pourrait
prendre un verre
de et prendre l'air en fait même si je
fais pas beau du coup on profite d'être
dehors et puis voilà un peu
de droite pour l'air beaucoup c'est un
peu pour ça échanger lieu aussi quoi
j'aime bien cette atmosphère un peu
agréable ce n'est qu'une question de
temps avant que les terrasses soient
victimes de leur succès avec l'arrivée
des beaux jours les tables seront
bientôt tout remplies